sie sind fürs ganze leben traumatisiert
ehemalige heimkinder die im katholischen
kinderheim eschweiler in den 1950 er und
60 er jahren sexuell missbraucht und
körperlich misshandelt worden frontal
berichtete schon 2010 über die gruppe
auch hermine schneider schilder damals
ihr leid sie kam als junge zur welt
musste im heim mädchenkleider tragen
wurde oft geschlagen und von einer
erzieherin missbraucht sie haben mich
belächelt sie hat mich ab geküsst sagt
mich in die badewanne eingesetzt sagte
chairman gemacht am genital gefühlt
möglich streichen der tatort von damals
heute fühlt sich hermine schneider als
frau doch ihr leben lang musste sie
gegen vorurteile kämpfen
der ehemalige heimbetreiber ein
katholischer orden hat sich nach
jahrelangem streit entschuldigt und eine
entschädigung von 8000 euro bezahlt
das haus der geschichte in bonn hat das
schicksal von hermine schneider
wissenschaftlich überprüft und für
glaubwürdig befunden
zeugnisse aus dem heim sind archiviert
kleiderbügel und sogar eine peitsche mit
denen die kinder geschlagen worden
im museum ist auch das megafon mit dem
hermine schneider jahrelang öffentlich
an klappte
beweise für die zeit ihrer
misshandlungen aufzusammeln und die
geschichte von frau schneider hat uns
überzeugt und wir sehen es als wichtige
dokumente um aspekte der heimerziehung
in der frühen bundesrepublik zu
beleuchten den fall von hermine
schneider sieht der landschaftsverband
rheinland ganz anders der lvr hat
mehrfach anträge auf opferentschädigung
abgelehnt der sexuelle missbrauch wird
als nicht glaubhaft abgetan das haus der
geschichte eines der bedeutendsten
museen hier in deutschland das glaubt
mir das kinderheim glaubt mir und die
kirche glaubt mir und auch diverse
gutachten aber hier vom 11 wird man als
lügner hingestellt ich bin da völlig
fassungslos ich habe mir fehlen die
worte dazu und auch andere behörden
setzten ihr zu
1974 wurde hermine schneider auf ihre
arbeitsfähigkeit hin begutachtet
das fatale ergebnis damals sie leider an
angeborenem schwachsinn und sei ein
arbeitsscheue psychopath daraufhin habe
sie auf anordnung des jugendamtes die
handelsschule verlassen müssen trotz
guter noten die folgen waren gravierend
denn ich durfte keine berufsausbildung
machen konnten damit keine vernünftige
ausbildung erlangen einen vernünftigen
beruf erlernen und war ein leben lang
immer in armut leben der lvr prüft seit
jahren ob armin schneider eine
opferentschädigung rente zusteht er
teilt auf nachfrage mit zitat der fall
von frau schneider macht uns sehr
betroffen weiter heißt es die behörde
stelle nicht infrage das freischneiden
ein kinderheim mit schlägen körperlich
misshandelt oder
der lvr verweist allerdings auf das
landessozialgericht nordrhein westfalen
das habe 2009 keinen kausalen
zusammenhang gesehen zwischen damaliger
gewalttat und gesundheitliche schädigung
heute grundlage ein gutachten das sei
völlig unwissenschaftlich und in der
wortwahl skandalös kritisiert professor
capella berater des bundestages in
missbrauchsfragen es wiederhole die
unhaltbaren fehleinschätzungen von 1974
schwachsinniger arbeitsscheue psychopath
ich halte das für einen skandal dass
deutschen sozialgerichte im jahre 2009
aber auch deutsche oberst der jugend wie
der landschaftsverband rheinland
solch ein gutachten das sich auf
theorien aus der ns-zeit stützt noch
anerkennt und zur grundlage gemacht für
die entscheidung über die ansprüche
eines opfers der alten heimerziehung für
hermine schneider war das kinderheim
eschweiler ein ort des grauens
ihrer hartnäckigkeit hat vielen
missbrauchsopfern in deutschland mut
gemacht ich kämpfe für meinen
seelenfrieden denn ich weiß was damals
passiert ist was uns angetan wurde und
ich werde weiter kämpfen gegen die
ignoranz solcher behorden der
landschaftsverband rheinland lehnt ein
interview ab von hermine schneider
fordert die renten behörde neue beweise
nach 60 jahren